si le corona virus est à l'origine de la
plus grosse crise sanitaire dans notre
histoire contemporaine
ils pourraient être aussi dans les
semaines à venir à l'origine d'une très
importante crise économique une crise
annoncée à laquelle chacun tente de
faire face avec ses arbres ainsi
geoffroy roux de bézieux président du
medef a déclaré que pour lutter contre
cette crise les français allaient devoir
faire un effort collectif
il faudra bien se poser tôt ou tard la
question du temps de travail des jours
fériés et des congés payés pour
accompagner la reprise économique est
facilitée en travaillant un peu plus la
création de croissance supplémentaire
une déclaration qui demande aux français
après plusieurs mois d'enfermement de
travailler plus pour rétablir le manque
à gagner de cette période de blocage du
pays
l'important c'est de remettre la machine
économique en marche et de reproduire la
richesse en masse pour tenter d'effacer
dès 2021 les pertes de croissance de
2020 une sortie de la part du patron des
patrons qui est loin de faire
l'unanimité sur les réseaux des milliers
de citoyens se sont offusqués face à
cette idée rejoint par plusieurs
responsables politiques comme xavier
bertrand mais qu'est ce qu'on veut on
veut rendre fous les français un
discours identique chez de nombreux
responsables de partis et partenaires
sociaux alors à votre avis les français
sont ils prêts à travailler plus pour
relancer l'économie et chérie est ce que
les français doivent travailler plus
après la crise du coronavirus c'est ce
qu'a demandé le patron du medef donc le
patron des patrons comme on l'appelle
est ce que vous trouvez que c'est une
bonne initiative de dire ça c'est
n'importe quoi
voilà alors mathieu non je trouve
qu'effectivement faux pas sont que c'est
une honte que j'ai entendu sur le patron
du medef parce qu'effectivement on est
en train de laisser entendre d'abord que
les français seraient responsables de ce
qui leur arrive
les français se sont tapés six mois de
gilet jaune où ils ont quasiment tous
crever de faim fermer leur société dans
les très difficile maintenant ils sont à
nouveau confiné il gagne plus d'argent
un français sur quatre est au chômage
toutes les petites pme sont en train de
fermer
on est dans une merde noire les gens ne
savent vraiment plus comment ils vont
pouvoir bouffer et on entre on a
expliqué que quand on va sortir de ça
toute leur congé payé leurs vacances les
systèmes de vacances vont éventuellement
être supprimé pour travailler qu'on va
peut-être travailler les jours fériés
pas c'est une tag donc ils sont
responsables de ça et encore une fois
c'est eux qui vont devoir travailler
plus 60 ans de ça je pense qu'on risque
d'aller au chaos total on va rendre les
français sous et je pense qu'on allait
vers une révolution si on continue de
sortir des bêtises pareilles
ce n'est pas à nous de payer ce virus
très bien aller barakat annick mais je
comprends très bien que ce que dit
mathieu mais objectivement si on se
regarde ce qui s'est passé dans le passé
effectivement on va tous va faire un
effort du monde du moins riches aux plus
riches
et c'est vrai que ils font ça tous
des effectivement je dis pas qu'il faut
tu pris des congés payés etc mais je
comprends très bien qu'aujourd'hui on
soit tous concernés qu'on doit tous
faire un effort alors à chacun à son
niveau
alors les plus faibles petit effort mais
les plus forts évidemment un plus gros
mais je suis pas d'accord avec toi c'est
pas il n'a pas dit qu'on était du vel
d'hiv du virus n'est pas vrai ce que je
sais pas j'ai passé voilà c'est pas ce
4e div 1 jean marc bonnet je pensais
bien que l'ancien syndicaliste mongi
révoqué parce que j'ai séquestré mon
parcours aller à leur terme
elle sait bien que je vais pas dire
assez normal oui oui à cette même
opposition à la cote des ministres c'est
toujours les mêmes à qui on a demandé
des efforts toujours toujours toujours
et les paroles qu'elle sait qui se
remettraient en question qui donneront
que moins de dividendes aux actionnaires
et qu'ils n'auront pas ce que tu es bien
beau mouvement tout le monde rigolait le
mans déjà dit l'infirmière en l'époque
qui est le colis des aînés
tout le monde est gentil les éboueurs et
traite qui m'attire parti qu'elle sera
fini tout ça démontre que je ne dis pas
dans la crise mais après et qui veut
qu'on recommande pas moi peu de choses
sur la rue il veut que les travailleurs
payent encore le court on commence à
travailler on va refaire passer la
semaine à caractère la réforme des
retraites le passo au travers il ya
plein cru estime qu ils sont malins les
politiques les mags alors saubot alors
il prenait soin beaucoup plus malin que
nous regardez regardez ils en ont parlé
hier soir dans le jt de 20h de france 2
vous allez voir que la proposition a
même été validé par le secrétaire la
secrétaire d'état à l'économie regarde
le pib a chuté de 6% au premier
trimestre alors pour rattraper une
partie de l'activité le patronat fait
une proposition mettre en place des
accords dans certaines entreprises
pour faire travailler davantage les
salariés et savent bien que si leur
entreprise est de nas et leur emploi est
menacé pendant attendre dans le respect
de la loi
je le redis en accord avec les
organisations syndicales
c'est pas un sacrifice c'est un coup de
collier cela pourrait passer par des
heures supplémentaires mais aussi la
suppression de jours fériés ou encore le
report de rtt
alors justement ils ont demandé aux
français ce qu'ils ont pensé en sur
france2 regarder ce petit micro-trottoir
qui a été diffusé hier soir regarde ça
me paraît pas aberrant non à situation
exceptionnelle acte exceptionnel
moi je suis dans le commerce on n'aura
peut-être pas le choix les acquis
sociaux doivent rester acquis sociaux
pensent que les genres assez souffert
comme ça pour en plus les faire
travailler alors et ils ont fait un
micro trottoir etc les personnes voilà
qui étaient dans la rue et les rares
personnes qui étaient dans la rue
forcément ce conan confinement jean
michel maire à ce que tu comprends ça
non mais je comprends pas du tout ça
creuse il s'assume en tant qu'ensemble
on est en vacances mais en vacances on
escompte fine et la grande majorité des
français sont stressés ce qui sont
confinés
bien sûr ils ont perdu leurs cadres
beaucoup chantent l'hymne est de plus en
plus de gens sont effondrés pas s'ils
ont perdu des membres de leur famille
sont morts et pour déneiger en sortant a
cependant un coup de bambou et
travailler encore plus soignée pour rien
nous on a besoin au contraire d'avoir de
la joie en sortant ait pas de cheminée
s'est enfui sur le boulot sophie cost je
pense qu'il ya un problème de timing en
fait avec cette annonce
malheureusement je comprends bien prédit
mathieu est ce que dit jean michel on
peut pas aller contre ces propos là
c'est vrai que les français sont rincés
épuisés et ruinés
malgré tout je pense qu'on n'aura pas le
choix je pense qu'il faudra qu'on passe
tous un effort et qu'on mette tous comme
comme l'a dit le ministre
on sera obligé de mettre un coup de
collier forcément pour we run et rené
choix oui voilà
j'espère qu'on va écouter liétout le
président a mené quelques minutes j'ai
écouté ensemble sur ces la voilà
j'espère qu'il va pas dans la parole pas
pour nous dire des conneries pareilles
geste qui va apprécier
enlever les taches claires et de petits
commerces des entreprises et non pas les
les champs soir
j'espère qu'il va nous dire des choses
concrètes qui vont relancer l'économie
et les coupes les petits commerces et
les petites pme pas nous raconter ma
part qu'on connaît